shireen mohithin has been unemployed for
about six months and is waiting for her
shot in the entertainment industry
there's a lot of competition out there
and that competition can make landing
the job even more difficult hearing that
a client's needs have been changed being
told to
lower my salary expectations because of
the job market the latest labor force
report by statistics canada shows
canada's unemployment rate has dropped
to 5.5 percent reaching below
pre-pandemic levels from february of
2020. experts say the news is a very
encouraging sign economics professor
christine neal says the quick rebound
has a lot to do with canada's income
support policies when people were laid
off or couldn't work because of covert
that at least their incomes didn't drop
and that that meant that their spending
didn't drop as much as it would have
otherwise and if that had happened that
would have contributed to a much
lengthier recession she says science and
our public health response also played a
role we got vaccines incredibly quickly
those have really meant that we have
been able to reopen the economy without
the risks that would have been there
otherwise but neil says we can't lower
our guards just yet we do need to keep
responding quickly in the face of
further in any further increase in
covert rates and deaths as the market
continues to rebound and more jobs open
up people like shireen will see more
opportunities it's just a matter of
being at the right place at the right
time charming samani global news